meine damen und herren sie werden sicher
auch gemerkt haben eine ganz besonders
fiese eigenschaft von corona ist ja
dieses virus macht ohnehin vorhandene
probleme gerne noch schlimmer beispiel
richter mangel
ja es fehlt ohne ende personal und die
folge sind total überlastete gerichte so
und da flattern jetzt eben auch noch
ohne ende neue corona verfahren rein
obendrauf laut deutschen richterbund
allein 20.000 strafverfahren mit corona
bezug geben noch um den ersten lockdown
wie soll man gegen so eine flut an
verhandeln haben die überarbeitete
menschen unseren gerichten denn
wenigstens die nötige ausstattung oder
oder schicke büros die schreibtischlampe
habe ich mir selber angeschafft gucken
sich mal diese uralten dinger der an
gott sei dank funktionieren sie zurzeit
alle also ich bin ja relativ groß mein
höhenverstellbaren schreibtisch sieht so
aus dass wir die wachtmeister holzklötze
der gelegte keine angst die holzklötze
werden natürlich vom gehalt abgezogen
deutsche richter und richterinnen
arbeiten regelmäßig 60 stunden wochen
relativ normal
und da gibt es wenig licht am ende des
tunnels denn in den nächsten zehn jahren
gehen 40 prozent von denen in renten
unsere gerichte werden so quasi zu einer
art jura bigpark eine folge des
personalmangels strafverfahren ziehen
sich brutal in die länge und werden am
ende immer öfter eingestellt vor allem
bei kleineren strafsachen aber auch beim
comex betrug eine der größten sauereien
der letzten jahrzehnte drohen gleich
mehrere fälle zu verjähren
was sollst du machen gegen die
aktenberge die sich da auftun
da sind so um die 162 160 bände akten
drin wie lange stehen diese kisten hier
stehen schon etwas länger kann sein dass
sie bald hin und hergeschoben worden
sind wo gerade platz ist immerhin ja das
war in dem fall tatsächlich ein
verfahren gegen rechte hooligans die
meisten von denen sind aber inzwischen
an altersschwäche verstorben allein 2008
10 endete über die hälfte der verfahren
ohne anklage was ganz klar auch mit
überlastung der staatsanwaltschaften zu
tun hat aber selbst darin liegt wie so
oft natürlich auch eine chance
deutschlands gerichte sind extrem
überlastet und jetzt auch noch 20.000
neue kroner verwahren
das heißt jetzt kriminell werden die
chance nicht in den knast zu wandern ist
größer denn je
sie sind solo selbstständige musiker und
dürfen nicht auftreten werden sie durch
drogendealer ein beruf mit zukunft
und selbst der schlechteste bauchredner
der welt findet immer arbeit als
bankräuber die runde gesperrte justiz
unsere soforthilfe für solo
selbstständige schöne aktion
ich appelliere daher wirklich auch mal
an die fairness unserer kriminellen
erläutert ihr wisst ja was ihr gemacht
habt oder und kennt auch ungefähr das
strafmaß super nice wer also wenn ihr
euch ab jetzt selber einbuchten könnte
ganz leicht einfach zur nächsten jva
gehen vor dem haupteingang rechts haben
wir so ein gartenzwerg hingestellt
darunter liegt der gefängnis schlüssel
beim rausgehen einfach wieder drunter
legen vielen dank von net von euch hier
ist aber nicht nur jammern gefragt meine
damen und herren sondern mithelfen genau
deswegen haben wir von der heute show
einen unserer besten zur richter
ausbildung geschickt also zum schnupper
crashkurs abdel karim lässt sich in
erfurt blitz ausbilden von einem richter
den sie schon kennen
es ist kein geringerer als der mann mit
den plätzen und am tisch
[Musik]
aber es ist doch schön aus hier wie
sonst kein bock richter zu werden für
das der richter beruf so spaß macht es
erstaunlich dass wir momentan so ein
mangel haben wir brauchen wirklich
dringend jede menge neue kolleginnen und
kollegen da führt kein weg dran vorbei
hier ging es vor drei jahren so da hatte
ich im sommer mehr verfahren als das
ganze letzte jahr vorher und von 26
sachen 22 hauptsache und da tritt ihnen
immer der schweiß auf die stirn weise
die innerhalb von sechs monaten
verhandeln müssen
das müssen sie die sache dem
oberlandesgericht vorlegen und wenn die
sagen das verfahren ist nicht gefördert
worden dann lassen sie die leute aus der
u haft heraus könnte mörder sein könnten
vergewaltiger sein dass kein richtiger
den antworten der richter mangel ist ein
sehr weiter das ist herr adams
justizminister von thüringen er hat hier
das sagen wie würden sie sagen kann ich
mich jetzt hier einbringen um den
richter mangel in thüringen den griff zu
kriegen
ja ich weiß ich habe gehört sie haben
schon studiert und erfolgreich
abgebrochen auch er also müssen uns
erfolgreich zu ende bringen zweite
staatsexamen zusammen 15 punkte beide
male mindestens befriedigend die
anforderungen sind schon deutlich
runtergefahren
das heißt sie gucken sich bewerber an
die sie vielleicht vor 23 jahren nicht
mehr eingeladen hätten und die frage ist
dann immer ob sie sie aufnehmen müssen
und wir würden es heute gerne so
hinkriegen dass sich innerhalb von ein
paar stunden so auf vordermann bringen
wirklich jeder mensch sagt wo war er die
letzten jahre immer die gleiche gericht
der angeklagte als das fahrrad stehen
lassen aber das schloss mitgenommen kann
sein dass ihre rolle sehr ernst nimmt in
der regel schon
ich war der erste der hier ein geführter
klub selbst zu verhandeln weil es anders
nicht mehr ging ja handel 3 samstag
wir hatten eine woche zeit als
angeklagter ja die die saßen in haft die
mussten kommen aber die anwälte hatten
angeblich keine zeit mir drohte der
protest zu platzen in der strafsache
gegen beeck wird die anklage der star
sam sda staatsanwaltschaft
was wird im moment hier in thüringen
mehr eingestellt richter oder verfahren
und wir müssen jetzt aber
überproportional junge leute einstellen
mehr als raus kommen um wieder das was
an lücken entstanden ist auch
aufzufüllen kann der staat vielleicht
mehr lernen von der privatwirtschaft
könnte man deutschland zum beispiel in
eine gmbh umwandeln
ich glaube du bist du gewissen grad ja
ab einem gewissen punkt nein also was
man machen kann ist halt sowohl in ich
würde sagen primären faktoren die halt
entscheidend sind dafür über den beruf
annimmt oder nicht dass man da was
ändert aber auch bei sekundären faktoren
die halt nicht dafür entscheiden sind
dass ich den beruf annehme die aber
trotzdem jetzt sind so was wie
beispielsweise firmen handy oder gratis
obst oder so was also kleineres europa
gibt es auch in großkanzleien
beispielsweise dass sie sagen da liegt
ein apfel
ja und dann würdest du dich freuen dann
können wir auch besorgen man kein stress
jetzt wissen sie was mich interessieren
würde
gibt es eigentlich ein land in europa wo
die richter weniger verdienen als die
richter in deutschland ja klappt
andauern
meine damen und herren ab heute weht ein
anderer wind
[Musik]
ruhe bitte im namen des volkes ergeht
folgendes urteil
herr karl lauterbach sie haben ab heute
talkshow verbot hiermit bestelle ich
zwei cheeseburger chicken nuggets
familien box und drei bürger ohne käse
die kosten übernimmt die staatskasse
ich habe gerne über mich aber ich habe
jetzt keine wahl vielleicht denn heute
eigentlich ein ganz angenehmer
gesprächspartner
man merkt doch dass ein bisschen jura
studiert haben also waren brauchbare
anfang keine weiteren fragen ja
it-service bruns weiß ich spreche mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe ja probieren sie doch
mal den kanal der heute show auf youtube
zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung